we're taking phone calls at 6 1 7 830
for 750 that is the only number where we
take phone calls so if you're calling
any other number and you're wondering
why you're not getting through that's
the reason why because it's 617 830 4750
let's start with name and town who's
joining us and where are you calling
from hey what's up David my name is art
and I'm from anaheim california all
right art checking in from the west
coast uh what what can we do for you
today well look first of all I want to
thank you because um before I listen to
your show I was like gives like a week
ago I was like a full-on Trump supporter
I was anti Hillary i mean i was on the
tram train wait a second art let me just
be you said a week ago before you
started listening to the show you were a
full-blown anti Hillary Trump supporter
and that this was not a process of many
months but you've been listening to show
one week and that's changed yeah like
two weeks we can have yeah well I mean
yeah it's crazy but um it is great but
logical I like it yeah so what I wanted
to ask is um I'm still kind of worried
that Trump might win because I mean I
don't know if you like he have like I
think there's a lot of my closet Trump
supporters who don't want to come out
publicly say they're supporting friends
well let's explore that I mean when you
were a trump supporter after until you
know one week of the david pakman show
converted you ought to be not voting for
Trump which were believing we're taking
very detailed notes over here about what
you're telling us um before you were a
hillary supporter would you publicly
tell people you were supporting Trump or
were you ashamed of it yourself look I
would do it the like very subtle it
wasn't I wouldn't really state my
opinion especially because I'm Hispanic
so like all my family and I my friend
there they hate Trump I mean to hate him
so no I was kind of like a closet
transporter yeah
and when Trump said that although he's
sure some mexicans are probably good
people but that there's a lot of rapists
and criminals in Mexico is not sending
over its best as a Hispanic Trump
supporter how did you rationalize that I
mean I'm telling you man I didn't I
didn't care i was anti Hillary etching
that well you know he said some are good
so I mean he probably means with him and
he's right you know i was i don't know i
mean i can't explain indeed i'm just
Tony I was like anti Hillary because I
was flicking into our stuff like I was
kind of listening to alex jones was okay
she's like he's a nut job yeah can I
that means i guess you can kind of see
can I ask specifically what uh what you
disliked about Hillary Clinton I mean I
don't know just what I was reading I get
on Alex Jones website right yeah yeah
like they were saying that she was like
a murderer and less she Hillary body
counts down yeah all that and that's I
was basing my my knowledge on this this
is an incredible call ladies and
gentlemen I mean this is one of the best
calls and most compelling and
fascinating that we've had I mean uh uh
wow art I can't thank you enough this
has been really really eye-opening and
let's let's check in again after the
election feel free to call in any time
okay all right thank you all right my
pleasure Wow Wow ladies and gentlemen I
mean just truly incredible Trump
supporter one week later not a trump
supporter based on the David Pakman show
I like it thanks Hilary is a murderer
and used to think Hillary Clinton was a
murderer based on Alex Jones his website